yeah I have all these teammates asking
me to spit up new projects for her but
each one requires special tweaks and
then I have to apply the standard
configuration that's it just use the
cloud deployment manager to create
projects oh that's the infrastructure
and configuration is code tool right
isn't that kind of hard to set up no not
at all if you use the card foundation
toolkit templates such as the project
Factory all right can we see how it
works
sure thing
the cloud foundation took it has a lots
of great templates to get started from
let's begin with some easy firewall
rules as a warm up looking up a template
at the CFT repository you will find a
readme how to use the template with a
ready to go example configuration first
let's go on the repo and jump into the
templates folder now copy the example
file and fill out the mandatory
properties about your environment in
this case the VPC name which is the
network where you want the firewalls to
live for now let's use the default
network make sure you enable the
required api's compute and deployment
manager and then we are ready to launch
the deployment using the G cloud CLI our
resources will be created via deployment
manager within a couple of seconds this
shows up in the cloud console
immediately if we go back to the config
and change some properties we can update
the resources during its lifecycle via
deployment manager if we refresh the
list of firewalls we can see the changes
finally by deleting the deployment we
clean up all the resources which we
created
now comes the real deal we create a
shared VPC host project adding sub
networks in it then we create a gas
project and attaching it to one of those
subnets first let's set our environment
variables and enable the required API is
based on prerequisite section of the
readme don't forget to allow deployment
manager to attach your billing account
to projects after copying and filling
out the example open the configuration
file and edit at the end because first
we create the V PC host project
now let's launch the deployment it
usually takes a couple of minutes to
create all of these resources
now we copy the network template example
and launch it with all the default
settings in the V PC host project which
we just created last step is to copy the
project example configuration again for
the guest project fill out the
environment properties and make sure we
are referencing the recently created
subnet we wish to attach this project to
after the same create command we can see
at the cloud console the two projects
the network with the subnets at the host
project and the attached guest project
there you go
you just implemented the automated
project Factory in your organization
check out our github repository the
deployment manager best practices and
some further bad side stories down at
the description and don't forget to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform contests
[Music]
you